[Música]
eu sou um ativador de futuros desejáveis
e foi no verão de 95 que tecnologia e
magia entraram juntas e se ativarão na
minha vida eu lembro como se fosse hoje
o primeiro computador da minha mãe
trouxe pra casa e se vocês estavam lá em
95 vão lembrar também era uma mistura de
uma televisão branca bege que a gente
não sabia direito que aquilo era capaz
de fazer tinha ouvido alguma coisa como
comper tempo espaço mas a família
decidiu fazer o primeiro experimento uma
viagem para frança dentro do livre para
que a gente pudesse ver a mona lisa a
monalisa via internet discada levou uma
hora e meia pra descer pixel a pixel
mas quando ela estava inteira ali a
gente conseguiu ter a nossa primeira
experiência de teletransporte
hoje em dia cada vez que você abre o seu
celular você é teletransportado para
algum lugar e essa fronteira de tempo
espaço é vivida todas as vezes mas não
era assim 95 outra coisa mágica também
aconteceu naquela mesma noite
eu consegui achar um arquivo com 24
fotos do brad pitt
háháhá bom para uma menina de 15 anos
para quem também esteve lá e significava
dois anos inteirinhos de revista
adolescente um capricho que a gente não
estava acostumado ainda mas a maior
mágica aconteceu semanas depois eu
viajei pra férias na casa dos meus avós
como geralmente eu fazia meu lugar
favorito ali era a biblioteca do meu tio
renê que era uma mistura de livia e
museu e tinha livros e peças e adorava
ficar lá
boa parte das sérias mas em especial um
livro me chamou a atenção ele vinha do
título assim eram os deuses astronautas
o autor havia viajado por vários lugares
do planeta todos aqueles sítios
arqueológicos de cidades que a gente
conhece como
aas do egito cheia de pirâmides até
aquelas pedras redondas que ninguém sabe
direito que o que faz até hoje
mas ele tinha uma uma proposta especial
para aquilo tudo ele falava que não
foram os deuses que ajudaram aqueles
povos antigos e ancestrais a fazerem
tudo aquilo
na verdade foram astronautas que
chegaram aqui transfiram tecnologia
eu não preciso dizer o quanto aquilo me
impactou mais uma fotografia especial de
um deus maia é a original essa vermelha
que está num tempo no méxico é do livro
era essa
bom eu não preciso dizer pra vocês que é
até meio difícil de enxergar parece um
ser que está em uma máquina que voa mas
uma parte da foto me chamou muita
atenção ele estava debruçado digitando
alguma posição que havia vídeos dos meus
pais as minhas irmãs
algumas semanas antes eu falei cara
limpa ele está digitando um computador
bom é isso foi o suficiente para ao
longo dos meus próximos 15 anos
eu também percorrer os mesmos caminhos
que o autor percorreu pra que eu pudesse
né naturalmente checar por mim mesma a
carreira seguiu pela lado a tecnologia
porque foi uma das ações adquiridas
naquele verão mas ela foi preciso lado e
é um privilégio está contando isso pela
primeira vez eu nunca contei em público
essa história
então para todo lugar que a minha
profissão me mandava geralmente tinha a
ver com as cidades empresas organizações
que já estavam buscando presente né e
expandido ou seja trazer o futuro
presente e era óbvio que a tecnologia
estava envolvido naquilo então eu ia
fazer uma reunião em londres e
magicamente olhava qual era a cidade ao
redor que eu podia visitar também essas
civilizações ancestrais
elas estavam muito próximas em pri eu ia
fazer um final de pesquisa de mestrado
na china em uma grande muralha ancestral
também estava lá eu ia visitar um
cliente na cidade do méxico e as
pirâmides de povos que a gente não sabe
direito quem eles são ainda
estava 40 minutos do aeroporto e eu fiz
muito disso na minha vida
a tecnologia do futuro com tecnologia do
passado e teve muitas reflexões e eu
poderia falar até amanhã sobre todas
elas mas a gente vai compartilhar duas
a primeira delas é que tecnologia de
verdade não tem a ver com fim se tem a
ver quanto uma quantidade de pessoas
conseguem entendê las e usá las com um
propósito que a maioria entende que é
necessário e isso aconteceu na em toda a
nossa história
se a gente pegar por exemplo os dados a
gente vê que eles são hoje o novo
petróleo e são francisco entendeu isso
muito bem lá nos estados unidos e deixou
todos os dados abertos para que os
cidadãos e as pessoas que lá vivem
possam produzir e ter conhecimento e
coclear em coisas com base naquilo que é
bem comum
mas eu também vi lá em cuzco que era a
capital do império inca a internet móvel
mais incrível de todas era uma que os
homens corriam com ela na cintura cheia
de nós que eles conheciam como nós que
falavam eles corriam por dois
quilômetros da capital do império no
centro do peru até lá em baixo na
argentina e até 72 horas
as informações que corriam de um lado
para o outro os primeiras partes desse
sinto eram dados do bem comum com a
cidade homens de mulheres animais grãos
dali pra frente tinha uma criptografia
que só a liderança sabia mas tudo que
era necessário para que a vida flui se o
progresso acontecesse todo mundo sabia
ler
quando a gente fala de automatização a
gente tem som do na coréia do sul com
todos os apartamentos com energia
estranhamento automatizado
mas a gente tinha machu picchu era
aquela cidade bonita na montanha e todas
as suas cidades ao redor com uma
quantidade de coisas tecnológicas na
parte de duto de água que aquela água
corria e corre até hoje uma das fotos
que vocês podem virar em cima é uma foto
que a gente tirou
e água tinha para todas as casas também
e funciona até hoje a energia solar é
necessário a gente precisa migrar de uma
vez por todas essas matrizes antigas
onde a gente tira dinossauro líquido da
terra e continua tentando mandar naves
para o espaço a base disso e de uma vez
por todas a entrar em matrizes limpas de
energia energia solar é uma delas
a gente vê cidades como copenhague na
dinamarca com todos os seus postes de
luz à base de energia solar
eles conseguem medir qualidade de ar a
partir dessa energia limpa e energia
solar também era que maias e as
civilizações do sambaqui saque do das
montanhas enfim catarinenses também
faziam mas era de um outro lugar eles
olhavam para as estrelas eles marcavam
sol e as estrelas através do que a gente
conhece como astro a economia ou
ecologia e desse lugar eles conseguiram
determinar desde o ideal para plantar
para acolher para recolher pra fazer
guerras pra recolher esse processo era
tudo baseado nessas leituras e elas eram
milimétricos que já visitou lugares como
esse
sabe que o sol bate milimetricamente
duas vezes por ano 21 de março a 21 de
dezembro que são os solstícios então
tecnologia não tem a ver com aquela
tecnologia que ainda vai chegar e que
está no futuro tem a ver com o quanto a
gente consegue capturar delas e
transformá las para o bem comum
a segunda reflexão que eu trago é
tecnologia eles o que é isso
tecnologia eu vou usar uma frase de um
autor que talvez você não conheça o nome
mas certamente conhecem a obra arthur
clara que escreveu 2001 uma odisséia no
espaço ea frase que eu uso para minha
segunda reflexão é essa daqui
ele disse que toda tecnologia madura em
distinguir veio da magia então
tecnologia madura ressignificada usada
para exponencial uma sociedade
encantamento puro e geralmente
está associado com pessoas que entendem
isso que significam tecnologias e ativo
naquele futuro ativadores de futuro que
produzem tecnologia
se a gente perguntar se e provavelmente
você olhar o lado e vê alguém
concordando com isso você deve ter
encontrado mais um deles porque nós já
somos muitos e se você perguntar para um
ativador de futuro qual é a tecnologia a
gente explicar a inteligência artificial
robôs automatização eles certamente vão
concordar que todo o trabalho que a
máquina faz melhor que o humano é um
trabalho desumano e não no sentido de
cruel mas no sentido de duro
eles sabem que a hora que o humano para
de ter medo de perder seu emprego pra
máquina e começa a fazer parcerias
a gente não vai ser substituir a gente
vai ser aprimorado um médico que se
permite ter um robô auxiliando no máximo
uma cirurgia é um médico que vai ter uma
cirurgia mas precisa um médico que se
permite ter uma inteligência artificial
juntando num diagnóstico é um médico que
vai ter um diagnóstico muito mais
individual um ativador de futuro que
entende o lado das realidades e mercy
vaz
ele vai dizer que aquilo não é videogame
que vai vivenciar todos os nossos jovens
e crianças
ele vai entender que nós seremos
construtores de mundos em cima do mundo
nós seremos arquitetos de memórias
porque essa foto que vocês estão vendo
já é a versão beta do google porque a
gente conhece como o mapa do planeta nós
já estamos é digitalizado pontinha
pontinho todos os lugares desse planeta
e dentro das versões dos óculos e ver se
vos a gente pode voar em qualquer lugar
pousar e ter experiências e não mais o
conhecimento como hoje as janelas nos
permite colocar a cabeça de quem vai
colocar o corpo inteiro lá dentro e
tirar memórias produzidas em conjunto
quando a gente fala de mídias sociais
a gente está falando de uma ferramenta
que vai ensinar que nós não estamos
separados que a separação é uma ilusão
nós temos atualmente
quase 50 por cento da população mundial
que dá pouco mais de três milhões e meio
de populares de pessoas conectadas de
alguma forma internet
olha a quantidade de revolução e
evolução que a gente conseguiu por conta
dessas trocas humanas
imagina quando for todos os humanos de
alguma forma tendo a possibilidade de
acessar essa inteligência essa
construção em rede é praticamente
transmissão de pensamento para qualquer
um a qualquer momento em três cliques
quando você pergunta para um ativador de
futuro qual é a tecnologia de blocking
fica fácil de entender quando muita
gente consegue dizer ah ah ah dinheiro
eletrônico é o bitcoin que eu já ouvi em
algum lugar eles vão dizer que sim
também é isso mas que basicamente o
futuro do dinheiro vai passar por aqui o
futuro do dinheiro significa o futuro da
confiança a onde uma plataforma com base
em tecnologias de blocos vai juntar pra
sempre quem produz algo com quem precisa
consumir aquele aula sem intermediários
que é onde a maioria das vezes a gente
tem os abusos de ganância e eles vão
afirmar com bastante certeza que embora
ainda não tenhamos todas as habilidades
100% ela vai mover a gente da economia
da ganância para a economia dá confiança
e aí um ativador de futuro apaixonado
por tecnologia vai dizer computação
quântica
provavelmente a sua favorita por ora ele
também vai ser honesto o suficiente para
dizer que não sabe todas as
possibilidades de uso porque é muito
embrionário ainda mas ela de verdade vai
mover a gente do binarismo documentação
atual que é 10 e 11 para as a computação
probabilística que é qualquer coisa
entre 0 inclusive 01 ao mesmo tempo eu
sei que é confuso mas imagina que em
nada se parece um computador
a gente vai ter que aprender o que é
isso que vocês estão vendo na foto é de
fato um computador quântico ele mais se
parece uma obra de arte e fica dentro
dessa geladeira com 16 camadas de
proteção a menos
cento e setenta e dois graus celsius um
reloginho acima do zero absoluto para
que a computação que acontece no nível
subatômico não seja inter ferida
seja pela o campo eletromagnético dos
nossos computadores e celulares dos
nossos corações
sim é muito poder
é um avanço tecnológico sem precedentes
na nossa história ea gente precisa tomar
a responsabilidade por esse momento
porque hoje do jeitinho que tá elas
ainda não estão todas maduras tem o tal
do mantra dos 20 anos em 20 anos não
está toda as maduras e conectadas
mas hoje nós já teríamos tecnologia para
resolver quase todos os problemas da
humanidade porque a gente não tem ainda
a humanidade então chamado é para que
nesse processo desses 20 anos cada um
olha para si e consiga reconstruir a sua
melhor versão que ativem se essa
tecnologia da melhor versão porque
quando nas civilizações dos deuses
astronautas alta tecnologia encontrou
baixo humanidade
era onde o fim estava próximo onde você
via decadência delas a gente entende sim
que a tecnologia em si é neutra como fim
mas ela jamais vai ser neutra enquanto o
uso humano ela pode ser sim a nossa
maior conexão liberdade ou a maior
controle escravidão da raça humana e
vamos ser cada um de nós ativando essas
tecnologias e esses futuros
os responsáveis para onde ela vai
entender
eu convido a vocês abandonarem o medo
que narrativas como black mirror o
exterminador do futuro matrix causa da
gente que chama de efeito black milk é
juntar o melhor da tecnologia
o pior do humano um ativador de futuro
que já entendeu que precisamos
ressignificar as tecnologias utiliza o
melhor da tecnologia com o melhor do ano
e aí eu escutei uma frase em 2002 do
ibama que traduz o que eu gostaria de
falar pra vocês
nós somos aqueles porque estávamos
esperando não vão haver outros
esse é um momento incrível pra tá viva
porque tá tudo amadurecendo nesse campo
tecnológico
e nós estamos amadurecendo profundamente
no campo mano dá pra ver em cada um de
vocês olhando pra mim agora
e aí eu fui ver se a fazer a dele mesmo
e eu descobri que não
ela também pertence a uma civilização
ancestral dos índios hope lá da américa
do norte
eu decidi
desde aquele verão de 95 mesmo que por
puro instinto que eu seria um ativador
de futuros desejáveis e esse é o convite
para cada um de vocês aqui porque nós
somos mesmo aqueles porque estávamos
esperando muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]